mcdonald's
report on wednesday that the chains
crispy chicken sandwich helped us
same store sales outpace 2019 levels by
double digits u.s same store sales
climbed 25.9 percent a quarter
and 14.9 on two-year basis the company
credited strong sales to its new
chicken sandwich which launched in
february and its famous orders promotion
with k-pops group bts
which includes an order of mcnuggets and
special sauces the fast food giant
reported fiscal core uh second quarter
net income of 2.222 billion 2.22 billion
or 2.95 dollars per share up from a 483
million
or 65 cents per share ceo chris
kamzinski
told analyst that 70 of mcdonald's u.s
dining rooms have been reopened
if a covet-19 resurgence doesn't occur
all of its u.s footprints
should have opened dining rooms by labor
day
gerard thoughts on this story yeah they
i
think it goes back to uh in our creative
right in creative we spend so much
time trying to be unique and original
and come up with the concept that
nobody's ever came up with
and at the end of the day there's only
seven stories and all you can do is tell
one of those stories that's been told a
million times your way
so instead mcdonald's the the the
harvard graduates they were like
you know what's really popular the
popeye's chicken sandwich let's do that
that's what they did you know what it
was the war was like popeyes and wendy's
and now they're
jumping into yeah they were like yeah
we're mcdonald's let's just do that they
made a popeye's chicken sandwich
they they made it for like a buck less
and it's it's it's all right i mean it's
pretty good
what i want and for all the
entrepreneurs out there you get this one
for free give me like one percent and
let me be the spokesperson of this all
right
why can't we have like a cauliflower
based like crouton cone like an ice
cream cone that you could put the salad
inside the cone so we can eat healthy on
the go like i've always thought like
like seaweed wrap or something like that
like you have like the sushi dude you
lost me at cauliflower like no but
instead of the carbs bro it's no carbs
so it's like
think like an ice cream cone and then
you put the dressing in there
we're going to go have it today i want
to have the cauliflower doesn't that the
best
actually gluten-free cauliflower costs
are pretty good
i thought you were going somewhere
totally different with this story if you
want to do something different
i thought you were different i thought
you're talking about papa chicken
sandwiches i lost you at cauliflower
yeah this is
this is um what an innovative campaign
take
pop culture icons and make commercials
around
the fried chicken do you know bts's do
you know who bts is
the k-pop group you actually know who
they are yeah we looked at the picture
but it's i don't listen you know okay
they're here they're the problems who
did they do before that travis scott one
of the biggest rappers in the world
but no they didn't they didn't oh just
justin timberlake they did mj obviously
and then they did bad bunny all they're
doing is taking the most famous
musicians in the world and being like
i like mcdonald's that's where i thought
you were going with like what a genius
i do wish that there were laws about
marketing though where you actually had
to show like the type of people who eat
your stuff not the type of people you
want like it should it shouldn't be
sexy bts people like it should be fat
asses like it should just be gerard
four in hungover morning he's just
dripping all over me barbecue sauce all
over your face
trying to get my my nuggets out of the
side while i'm driving with the left
that should be the commercial they
shouldn't be allowed
has there ever been a drunk guy in a
beer commercial it's always like people
playing volleyball looking sexy and
stuff
it should just be like you know making
love ultra hanging out with their panda
and their pants watching their eighth
hour of nfl sunday football
yeah no that's exactly you guys did you
guys get that out of your system that
was good that was very nice exchange
right there with uh
trying to get the job as a mcdonald's
cmo they're probably not going to hire
you so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you